laurent moutons bêlent il est conseiller
communal et porte-parole du parti n va
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur arte
france alors visiblement ce confinement
elle a l'air compliqué en belgique ait
eu des émeutes samedi après-midi en
banlieue de bruxelles après la mort d'un
jeune de 19 ans qui tentait d'échapper à
un contrôle de police
est ce que ces émeutes elles sont liées
à ce confinement selon vous oui à ce
stade il est difficile d'établir un lien
direct avec le confinement
il est clair qu'une certaine lassitude
commence à se ressentir dans le cherche
des beaucoup beaucoup d'habitants de la
capitale belge
parce que des incidents ont eu lieu dans
notamment dans la commune anderlech et
la commune voisine à la vie on a dépassé
la barre des 3500 morts et fait beaucoup
à l'échelle de votre pays qui compte 11
millions d'habitants est ce qu'il est
une surmortalité en belgique par rapport
aux autres pays européens et dans le
monde
il est difficile à dire parce que jusque
là les mesures prises par les autorités
contre les autorités belges semblaient
porter plutôt leurs fruits parce que
l'explosion des chiffres ces derniers
jeux vous constaterez se sont plutôt
manifesté dans les centres des
répondants dans ce genre d'établissement
où on a des personnes qui présente déjà
une 104 assez fragile un autre élément à
ne pas négliger c'est que c'est des
personnes qui dans certains cas ont été
contaminés par le personnel soignant
donc des mesures ont été prises à
l'étendue du pays
mais dans les hôpitaux les personnels
soignants a été exposé à la pandémie
voilà on en paye maintenant le prix est
ce que vous avez sentiment comprend bien
la mesure de la gravité de cette
pandémie tout à fait ça c'est indéniable
mais il le regard que l'on porté sur la
gestion de cette crise par le
gouvernement
je pense que la gestion est plutôt
responsable on a tout le monde a été
pris de court quand vous voyez comment
cette pandémie s'est manifestée à
l'échelle planétaire en france
vous êtes en italie aux états-unis par
personnes y étaient préparés on a vu
comment cela ce aînés s'est développé en
chine
on était loin de se douter que cela
allait gagner à aller gagner l'europe
est aussi trucks arrivé ici je crois que
la belgique est l'un des premiers pays à
avoir réagi de manière assez pro active
c'est que fait que les cas même les
cadets décès constatés c'est pas chez
auprès des monsieur madame tout le monde
les chiffres ont explosé dans les
maisons de repos dans l'est dans les
maisons de retraite mercredi normalement
vous serez fixés sur la prolongation du
confinement quels sont les scénarii
possibles
je crois qu'il ya simplement deux
scénarios possibles où je dirais 3 le
premier scénario c'est que le
confinement soit totalement levé et le
deuxième scénario c'est tout à fait le
contraire a dit que le confinement soit
prolongée ce pas de deux semaines où
soit d'un mois question de voir comment
la pandémie va évoluer s'il y aura une
voie rapide ou bien si la situation est
totalement sous maîtrise à ce contrôle
est le troisième scénario serait celui
d'un d'une baisse progressive des
mesures de confinement
quel scénario privilégié je pense que la
santé publique on ne s'amuse pas avec la
santé des gens
quelques mesures qui sera prise que ce
soit celle d'une levée totale d'une
levée partielle elle doit vraiment être
est justifié s'il le faut s'il le faut
ça ne me dérangerait vraiment pas que
les mesures de confinement soit a soit
prolongée mais à côté de ces impératifs
de santé publique
il ya également les impératifs d'ordre
économique parce qu'il faut sauver
l'économie
il faut empêcher éviter que l'économie
ne continue progressivement a
continuellement dégringolé donc il va
falloir voir les ports de l'économie
nationale qui peuvent répondre
complètement qualifiés et des métiers
essentiels si dans ce métier là les
activités peuvent répandre quitte à
observer toutes les précautions d'usagé
une dernière question rapidement pour
vous s'il vous plaît la question des
masques
est ce que est ce que c'était tout aussi
un casse-tête en belgique comme ici en
france il est clair ça a été un casse
tête
bon on s'est dit la situation est
critique
c'est pas le moment de commencer à faire
le procès de la gestion de cette crise
de cette crise sanitaire à échelle
planétaire
là le contexte plaide plus se plaît se
prête plutôt à la conjugaison de tous
nos efforts de toutes nos énergies ou
venir à bout de cette pandémie
et ce n'est qu'après on pourra faire
l'évaluation de la gestion de cette
crise mais il est clair qu'il ya eu des
défaillances à certains endroits partie
la nva a soulevé la colère des masques
déjà depuis le mois de janvier le
ministre la ministre de l'économie avait
été interpellé sur cette problématique
elle avait assuré aux représentants des
parties à la chambre à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'assemblée nationale n'y
avait aucun problème à ce niveau là
lorsque la crise s'est fait attraper à
frapper fort on s'est rendu compte que
ces réponses ne reposait pas sur grand
chose
merci beaucoup laurent notamment et je
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller
communal porte parole du parti nv en
belgique
c'est à moi de vous remercier